[Music]
on this Tuesday night escape from Gaza
the first group of Canadians gets out of
the Gaza Strip what they've endured
blood came out from my ears when they'll
get home plus Israel's push to reoccupy
Gaza
indefinitely held hostage for more than
a month do they get asleep do they get
beaten families wait in agony for
answers and the release of their loved
ones for en sacrifices the mission to
honor thousands of Americans who
defended and died for
Canada and a custody battle of sheer
determination thankfully the police have
just arrived the fight over who gets to
keep Fiona who is no longer Britain's
lonely as
sheep global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
Canadians are finally getting out of
Gaza one month after the surprise
attacks by Hamas on Southern Israel
triggered the Israeli Siege and
bombardment at the same time calls for a
ceasefire are being rejected by Israel's
prime minister who says the hostages
must be released first among the more
than 2 million people trapped in Gaza
are hundreds of Canadians and their
families some have told us they feared
for their lives every moment of the day
80 were on a list to leave through the
Rafa Crossing to Egypt today including
this boy and his
family it was very Terri fing it was
really hard to get out uh everyone in
Gaz is very scared and doesn't have a
place to go uh can't go to a safe place
the Canadian government says 59
Canadians on the list made it into Egypt
today but there are hundreds to get out
so we're going to continue to work day
and night uh until all Canadians and
their families are out of Gaza this is a
priority for this government and in a
signal of a new stage in the conflict
Israel says its forces are now now
battling Hamas Fighters deep inside
gaza's largest city more on that in a
moment but we begin with Mike Armstrong
and a warning some of the images in his
story may be
disturbing they have waited for weeks in
a war zone Canadian citizens with the
passports to prove it finally told
they'd be getting out of Gaza Crossing
into Egypt they're leaving the bombing
behind but carrying the nightmares with
them very terrible I'm 71 years old I'm
tired I got I got bombed and then I have
a blood came out from my
ears Global Affairs candidate now says
there are about 400 Canadians and
eligible family members trying to get
out of
Gaza this woman is married to a Canadian
their baby was born by cesarian Just 2
weeks ago in Gaza this boy is from
Toronto he says he and his family spent
much of their time praying to stay alive
when just dying for no reason why we're
just innocent people that never did
anything yeah the Canadians who make it
across are met by officials from the
Canadian embassy in Egypt they're taken
to Cairo and will then have 72 hours to
leave the country and head to Canada
what they are leaving behind is a Gaza
Strip essentially cut in two the Israeli
military says it now controls a stretch
of land that runs east to west across
the middle of Gaza splitting Gaza City
off from the rest it has in recent days
opened a corridor for a few hours at a
time for gazans to leave Gaza City
Israeli Defense Forces are sending out
messages saying if people stay in the
north they're staying in a war
zone if they move to the South the IDF
says it will be moving in aid for
them in a statement Tuesday night
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu said his troops are now
operating inside Gaza City and incre
inreasing the pressure on Hamas with
every
hour the situation in Gaza is according
to Doctors Without Borders catastrophic
shortages of basic needs like food and
water are critical and it says without a
ceasefire it can't plan or organize ways
to help if there are heroes in this
situation one United Nations official
says it would be Palestinian healthcare
workers who stayed on the job despite
the condition
and despite the danger they're not only
having to decide whether to run and try
to save their own lives and going away
from hospitals which are under
evacuation and bomb threats attack
threats um but also they have their own
families now there is a new debate
Brewing over the question what comes
next Netanyahu is saying Israel would
likely be responsible for security in
Gaza after this conflict meaning a
reoccupation well his closest Ally is
pushing back on that already the White
House says it does not support Israel
occupying Gaza and that there have to be
conversations about what governance in
Gaza looks like going forward Donna all
right Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem
tonight
thanks the death toll in Gaza keeps
Rising the Hamas Ron Health Ministry
says more than 10,300 people have been
killed 2third of them women and children
and eight agen say about 1.5 million
people have been displaced from their
homes a top Israeli Commander said today
its forces are putting great pressure on
Hamas inside Gaza City and while the
country's prime minister said today he'd
consider tactical little pauses there
will be no ceasefire unless hostages are
released the families of those hostages
have lived in agony for 32 days now one
mother has made a plea to the leaders of
the US and Israel to bring her daughters
15-year-old daphna and 8-year-old Ella
home if you are unable to bring my girls
home she says put me in Gaza if only I
could hold them and tell them everything
will be all right and that mom is here
no matter what only five of the more
than 200 hostages have been released the
families of the others don't even know
if their loved ones are still alive and
worry the world has stopped caring
Danielle Hamin on how they're trying to
keep hope alive and warning some of the
details in her story are
disturbing this is a country still very
much in shock a month on since the worst
civilian massacre in Israel's history
they pay
tribute even on Israel's main
Airline
[Music]
1400 dead and more than 200 still
believe to be held
hostage among them are about 30
children the youngest just 9 months old
baby kir bbus had just learned how to
crawl and that's his father Yen who
can't get enough of him
baby kir is now 10 months old and his
relatives are tormented by the thoughts
of what the days are like in the tunnels
where they suspect he his four-year-old
brother Ariel and both their parents are
being held what do they
eat do they have something to eat the
baby does he get
formula do they get asleep do they get
beaten
on October 7th Hamas Fighters drilled
open their front
door by then the family was hiding in
the safe room but how do you force a
baby to be
quiet I can hear their screams yden
wrote in a message to his sister be
quiet she replied we're trying he
said within hours this video surfaced
online showing a terrified Shiri bis
clutching her two redheaded young
boys at one point the attackers say
protect her she has babies let them know
we are
Humane yden is seen covered in blood
taken away on a motorcycle the
grandparents would later be found dead
right now what we believe is until we
get a loved ones back there should be no
ceasefire on the Gaza Strip the more
civilians die on the other side do you
not fear that that could impact the way
your family is treated I'm not a
politician and I'm not a military
strategist I just know that my family is
there worried and they want them home
with
[Music]
me the Israeli intelligence apparatus
failed his family on October
7th does he trust it to bring them back
sometimes people make mistake mistakes
sometimes it's horrible mistakes like
the one that we have right
now I have no other choice but to
believe them even a month on and the
scale of what unfolded here is still
unclear Some of the Dead have yet to be
identified what's beyond any doubt is
that the attack on October 7th will
shape Israel's politics for decades to
come Donna Danielle thanks journalists
know there are risks covering conflicts
but the risks in Gaza are unpreceded
precedented according to the committee
to protect journalists the four weeks of
Israel's war on Hamas have been the
deadliest period for journalists since
1992 when it began documenting
fatalities most of the journalists who
died worked in Gaza this is the funeral
for Muhammad Abu hatab who was killed in
an Israeli air strike the cpj says 37
journalists and media workers have died
since October 7th 32 were Palestinian
four Israeli one was Lebanese eight
journalists are reported injured three
are missing nine have been
arrested Salman al- Basher was reporting
live when he learned his colleague had
been
killed these helmets do not protect us
he says they're just slogans that we
wear we are victims live on air losing
our lives one after the
[Music]
other
families of journalists are dying too
this is alzer's bureau chief in Gaza
burying his wife daughter son and
Grandson now that Israeli forces have
begun their ground offensive into Gaza
they have told news agencies the safety
of journalists cannot be
guaranteed most of those journalists
live in Gaza and cannot leave even if
they wanted
to Montreal police are investigating
what they suspect were two Molotov
cocktails found at a synagogue and a
Jewish Community Center investigators
searched for evidence after police say
what appeared to be firebombs were
thrown at the buildings overnight the
damage was minor and no one was injured
ashes and Charing were visible on the
synagogue's front door this morning no
arrests have been made and police are
asking Witnesses or anyone with footage
of what happened to come forward
Israel's war on Hamas is expected to to
the agenda at a meeting of G7 foreign
ministers in Japan Canada's foreign
affairs minister Melanie joli is there
they'll also be discussing challenges in
the Indo Pacific region on Monday Tokyo
Japan held its first missile evacuation
drill since 2018 it's a response to a
series of recent missile test launches
by North Korea as NE through garcher
reports a Canadian military Captain who
met with his North Korean counterpart
told Global News the threat is more
serious than
ever Transit passengers in Japan are
heading into a lower section of a subway
station it's the first missile
evacuation drill in Tokyo in
years This Disaster prevention official
said the Japanese government has been
requesting this training because of an
increase in information about missile
launches from North
Korea there have been a series of recent
test launches from North Korea including
a missile that flew over Japan's
Southern Islands in August triggering
the country's Nationwide alert system I
think that was very much a wake up call
for a lot of Japanese who I think maybe
didn't pay attention to defense and
security issues as much before that
Naval Captain Robert watt spoke to us
from on board a Canadian military
Mission flight he says Japan is
undergoing some of the most significant
changes to its security strategy since
the second world war 5 years ago there
probably would have been protests in the
street but now I think the public in
general and certainly the government um
have kind of taken a more realistic
approach to defense the US military base
in Japan is regularly used by Canadian
Armed Forces members taking part in
operation neon to enforce un sanctions
against North Korea this is a small part
of Canada's larger aim to support you
know a free and open Indo Pacific to
support a rules-based international
order Global news's Jeff simple
interviewed watt in 2018 when he was
posted at the UN command in South Korea
in charge of monitoring and patrolling
the demilitarized zone or DMZ he made
history when he arranged a face-to-face
meeting with his North Korean
counterpart I'm actually the only UNC
officer that stepped into a room with
the North Korean army at all watt says
Canadian soldiers remain stationed at
the UN command in South Korea and they
know someday soon it could become a
Battleground I think the risk of of uh
of escalation is higher than ever as
these residents dashing for cover in
Tokyo marked the latest sign of Japan's
worries over the growing threat from the
nuclear arm North Nea global
news we work didn't work coming up the
onetime darling of Wall Street files for
bankruptcy
protection facing pressure to address
Canada's housing crisis the federal
government says it will build more than
2,800 homes on federally owned
properties in Calgary Edmonton Ottawa
and St John's there were opportunities
to make better use of these properties
even even before the pandemic but the
hybrid work model developed since the
pandemic presents a significant
opportunity to consolidate office space
the government says it's on track to
build more than 29,000 homes on public
land by 2029 at least 300 units will be
designated as affordable housing Canada
needs more than 4 million affordable
homes that's according to the office of
the federal housing Advocate we work the
office sharing firm once valued at more
than $47 billion US has filed for
bankruptcy protection it is a stunning
fall for the firm and will give it
protection from its creditors and
landlords as it restructures its vast
debts filings show wework is looking to
get out of five Canadian leases the
company says locations outside the US in
Canada will not be
affected still ahead the push to honor
Americans who fought for Canada in the
Second World
[Music]
War
as Canadians prepare to remember the
fallen on Remembrance Day there is a
push to honor nearly 10,000 Americans
who fought and died for Canada before
the US entered the second world war
their unique roles have long been
ignored by the US Jackson prco reports
on the effort on both sides of the
border to fix that an American army
officer inspects US citizens who have
enlisted with the Royal Canadian Air
Force by 1941 it was no secret that
Americans were streaming across the
border to fight for Canada there are
about 2,000 American recruits in
Canada's Air Service thousands
volunteered at a time when their own
country was still officially neutral in
the war famed Canadian Ace Billy Bishop
led the recruitment effort at hotels
across the us
8,864 Americans joined the Royal
Canadian Air Force to fly and fight for
us because they knew Adolf Hitler was
coming more than 800 of those Americans
one in 10 never made it home their
service and sacrifice were all but
forgotten dense black smoke after the
attack on Pearl Harbor drew the us
directly into the war decades later
Canadian military researcher Carl cargar
noticed something unusual while pouring
over records of Canadian bomber Crews
there was amongst all these Canadian
Lads killed in World War II American
from New Hampshire American from Texas
and one from New Jersey Alfred Joseph
Parkin that's him getting his wings in
Ottawa Michael Parkin grew up hearing
about his father's cousin Alfred he
found it hard to believe the family tale
of an American who trained in Canada and
went missing on a bombing run off the
Dutch Coast because that was impossible
right but it wasn't Michael went on to
become a pilot in the US Marine Corps
over the years he learned more about men
like Al
he was haunted by the idea of Forgotten
service and sacrifice when somebody's
flying a military aircraft in combat and
they simply disappear and their story is
never told it's like they did it for not
and that's not right to this day the
Americans who fought for Canada are not
recognized on the pentagon's lists of
those killed or missing in action their
families don't get the recognition their
families don't get to tell their stories
there is an effort on both sides of the
border to change change that in
Washington there are calls to award the
Congressional gold medal to every
American who joined the rcaf these are
from the squadron's operations records
Michael Parkin is hoping to go even
further he wants to locate the final
resting places of men like Alfred men
who died in service of their country by
fighting for another one it was
important it mattered to the families it
mattered to America plainly and when we
forget our stories we don't heal from
trauma Jackson PR Go Global News
Stafford
Virginia on Saturday Global News we'll
have special coverage including a live
presentation of the Remembrance Day
service in Ottawa our coverage begins at
10:30 a.m. eastern on global and on all
of our streaming platforms the
extraordinary Rescue of this solitary
Sheep next what's Fiona up to
now our final story tonight is about
Fiona the Sheep Fiona spent two years
stranded at the bottom of a steep
Scottish cliff and became known as
Britain's loneliest sheep until a
treacherous rescue took place over the
weekend Redmond Shannon has Fiona's
remarkable tale she's living inside a
cave herself just solely by herself for
at least 2 years from being forgotten
for most of her life stuck at the bottom
of this sheer Cliff after a tumble as a
we lamb Fiona suddenly became the focus
of a daring custody battle we believe we
found a passage that we can get down to
and rescue her and that's what we're
going to do Animal Rights group animal
Rising wanted to bring her to a
sanctuary we were wanting to go and
visit sheep again this morning but this
time the farmer asked us not to but
during this time he covertly smuggled
sheep out sheep fans this is the biggest
story that I've ever broke youtubing
sheep farmer Camy Wilson says the
landowner called him to get the job done
instead that's not it that's all they
are Fe Fiona as we've named her and this
is the team they scaled the cliff to
bring her to a petting zoo but waiting
there ahead of them was the other flock
they're outside of the farm and with
pickets up saying free Fiona which is
completely ridiculous and thankfully the
police have just arrived I can see them
outside Fiona brought in dead to a
secret Bara shop for a long overdue
mutton makeover if we left her a good
inch or inch and a half cover she looks
quite good do you know think and after a
second covert transfer she finally
arrived at the petting zoo the unheard
of Adventure finished at last how's that
how's that for a good news story Redmond
Channel Global News
London pretty good I'd say that is
global national for this Tuesday I'm
Donna FZ and tonight's your Canada is
out of this world these are the
spectacular first images from the newly
launched euklid Space Telescope
developed by the European Space Agency
it's part of a mission to unlock the
secrets of dark matter and dark energy
believed to make up 95% of the cosmos
uclid will spend the next six years
surveying about a third of the sky with
the goal of building a 3D map of the
so-called Dark Universe thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]